there are many reasons why the world
loves Jason Momoa he stole and broke
hearts on Game of Thrones
he made a splash as Aquaman in Justice
League and will do it again in his own
standalone movie this year and his
tattoos and hair inspires serious style
Envy but we have another item to add to
the list Momoa recently took a photo
with two fans that the world can't stop
laughing about
Liz Medan dorp who goes by the username
to for joy on imager attended Denver
Comic Con back in June where she had the
chance to take a picture with the Game
of Thrones alum she explained on imager
I told my husband I wanted a picture
alone with Jason Momoa but he wasn't
comfortable with that so her husband
Anthony Middendorf hopped into frame but
Momoa ended up getting the last word
when he used one arm to pose with Liz
and the other to push her husband away
Momoa later added a cherry on top of the
priceless picture by signing his
autograph directly over a hymn Finney's
face
Liz shared Momoa was all about it when
he saw the print out to sign it he said
this is amazing Liz later revealed to
board Panda that her husband's
discomfort actually stemmed from not
wanting to spend so much money on a
photo if he wasn't going to be in it and
that Momoa was totally on board with the
joke when the couple pitched it to him
she continued
Hellyeah was Momoa 'he's immediate
response before I knew it the camera
flashed and everyone in the booth around
us was laughing as we were shuffled
toward the exit I heard Momoa call out
my man that's gonna be the best one over
3,000 comments on reddit later it's safe
to assume Anthony was more than happy to
be shoved in the face by the mega
muscled superstar thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to